one of the most popular questions that I
get from investors or Market
participants is whether Bitcoin is going
to be banned in the United States in
order to understand why people are
asking this question we must travel back
in time to 1933. the only thing we
have President Roosevelt in the United
States required through executive order
6102 that all American citizens turn in
their gold to the Federal Reserve during
this time the thought process was that
the U.S government needed to confiscate
all gold which is private property of
these U.S citizens in order to stabilize
the economy executive 6102 was the first
time that the United States government
took this type of action and now it has
people who are looking at Bitcoin or
other cryptocurrencies spooked will the
US government replicate executive order
6102 and come after your Bitcoin or your
cryptocurrencies I should first start
this answer by saying I have no clue I
don't have a crystal ball but I do think
that there are a couple of crucial
differences between gold in 1933 and
Bitcoin in 2023
first is Bitcoin has a very different
structure to it it is built on
cryptography and as long as you hold
your private keys that Bitcoin is yours
it is very hard to confiscate an asset
that is protected by that Shaw 256 or
buy those private Keys ultimately there
are hundreds of millions of people both
in the United States and around the
world combined that hold Bitcoin that
would have to turn over private Keys
which are just words two the US
government in order for them to take
control some of them would comply but
some would not and it would be nearly
impossible for the U.S government to
determine who had lost their Bitcoin and
who still held it now I'm not suggesting
that people should go and actually try
to actively go against the law but I do
think that there's a subset of people
who would do it second the United States
government doesn't necessarily benefit
from holding Bitcoin that it confiscates
from U.S citizens if they simply wanted
to hold that Bitcoin in the Federal
Reserve Treasury and they wanted to see
how that balance sheet could grow over
time that would be great and given that
there's only 21 million Bitcoin they
would have a larger percentage of
Bitcoin on a global scale but the US
dollar is not backed by Bitcoin and
there is no other use for Bitcoin inside
of the US government other than holding
it as a reserve asset and so holding
Bitcoin through confiscation of U.S
citizens wouldn't necessarily solve
problems that the government face in
terms of the deficit the Social Security
fund running out or any of the other
liabilities that it is responsible for
instead the Bitcoin that would be
confiscated from U.S citizens would
simply allow the government to take the
assets and then sell it for more dollars
to go ahead and cure those dollar
liabilities in some weird way the
government would be taking Bitcoin from
one U.S citizen to only turn around and
sell it back to another U.S citizen this
means that the confiscation would end up
only being a revenue driver it wouldn't
actually end up with Bitcoin in the US
government's hands last but not least is
the idea of Mining and so there is this
whole school of thought that maybe
actually the US government won't come in
and try to confiscate Bitcoin the asset
itself maybe instead the US government
will look to confiscate mining equipment
and try to actually control a large
portion of the mining hash rate globally
we know that after the 2021 shutdown of
China in the hash rate Wars that a lot
of that hash rate moved to the United
States it is estimated that over 30
percent of all Global hash rate is now
within U.S borders and the state of
Texas alone has about 10 percent of
global hash rate if the United States
government was to step in and try to
confiscate mining equipment they would
have a much easier time confiscating the
hardware than they would confiscating
the private keys of Bitcoin holders
around the United States but just
because you actually control that mining
hash rate doesn't mean that you control
Bitcoin first off you wouldn't even have
51 percent of all hash rate and second
of all even if you did have 51 or more
of all hash rate that doesn't
necessarily give you control of the
network you still have the node
operators and you still have various
other Market participants that would be
able to reject various changes that the
miners would try to push through another
part to the confiscation question is
that maybe the United States will just
ban ownership of Bitcoin they would do
this for private citizens and companies
alike but the problem is that the United
States only has 330 million citizens and
there are almost 8 billion people
globally when I worked at Facebook in
the early 2010s what I found was that 87
percent of the users of that platform
were outside of the United States I
don't know the exact numbers when it
comes to bitcoin ownership because it's
hard to measure but my guess is that
majority of people who actually own
Bitcoin and use it are outside of the US
already if the United States was to ban
ownership of Bitcoin my guess is that
would just increase the ownership of
Bitcoin elsewhere and so in some weird
way the United States would be be simply
shooting themselves in the foot and
pushing the adoption globally I don't
think that's something that the United
States government is willing to risk
another data point that I like to point
to is that there are multiple
congressmen or Senators that now hold
the asset themselves almost 15 percent
of the US population is estimated to
hold Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies and my
estimation is that at some point in the
future we will get a Bitcoin or as
president now many people will hear me
say that and they think that the future
president will run on some sort of
Bitcoin agenda but that's not what I'm
saying right now we have an equity
holder as President we had a real estate
holder as the last president neither one
of these candidates ran on the
possession of a certain financial asset
instead they simply have allocated their
personal portfolio to certain Financial
assets and they became president based
on other pretenses and so now we have an
equity holder as president but I don't
see the equity investors all running
around and celebrating I believe in the
future the president of the United
States will have Bitcoin as one of many
investment assets they hold in their
personal portfolio and so while yes the
Bitcoin Community will be able to claim
victory and say that there is a
bitcoiner as president it may not be
exactly what you're thinking and so
naturally the question will the United
States go ahead and confiscate Bitcoin
will they ban ownership of Bitcoin or
will they do something so abrasive that
it would change the investment profile
of the asset I don't think that is going
to happen I don't think that the United
States government is incentivized to
actually go ahead and confiscate Bitcoin
I don't think that the confiscation of
Bitcoin would solve their dollar
liability problem and I also don't think
that the United States government going
in and actually confiscating mining
Hardware would solve many of their
problems either now what I do think is
likely to continue to occur moving
forward is that there will be increased
scrutiny from regulators and other types
of organizations there could be an
increase in taxation or various
regulations that come companies and
investors have to comply with in this
world it would be an abrasive stance for
the US government to take and it would
disincentivize ownership of Bitcoin or
other types of assets but it is very
different than a full-on confiscation
given what we saw play out in 2020 in
the following years I think that there
is an entire portion of the population
that is much more sensitive to
government overreach there is many more
lawyers that are willing to stand up and
claim that something is unconstitutional
and I tend to think that the internet
has really created a transparency and a
velocity of information that rallies
people in record time so will the United
States confiscate Bitcoin my answer is
no but that doesn't mean that they won't
become more abrasive that doesn't mean
that they won't increase taxation or
regulation and it also doesn't mean that
you shouldn't continue to pay attention
the best practice when holding Bitcoin
is to hold your private Keys make sure
you're educated before you try to do it
make sure you read through various
pieces of information tutorials or or
all of the materials from the company
that you want to use their Hardware it
is something that is still Technical and
complex but not your keys not your coins
and so as I continue to watch this space
evolve maybe I'll change my mind in the
future but as of right now I don't think
the US government will confiscate your
Bitcoin